[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des carbonates city c'est un jumeau
numérique simula bhl qui est une
expérimentation qui est fait sur le
territoire de l'agglomération paris
saclay qui nous permet de numériser tout
notre territoire pour pouvoir
expérimenter des scénarios énergétiques
c'est comme un grand jeu vidéo un grand
sin city qui nous permet d'avoir des
simulations des estimations et pouvoir
voir au cas par cas quels sont les choix
énergétiques les plus pertinents pour
notre territoire
des carbone city c'est une innovation
technologique inédite en france et en
europe c'est le fruit de la
collaboration entre trois acteurs très
complémentaires l'agglomération
paris-saclay pionnière sur les questions
environnementales et de spécialistes en
modélisation simulation et aide à la
décision pour les systèmes complexes
cosmo tech leader des jumeaux numérique
symlabs et l'institut de recherche
technologique systémique
des carbonates city permet aux décideurs
publics d'imaginer différents scénarios
possibles pour les futurs aménagements
énergétique du territoire et d'en
comparer leur impact carbone dans les
années à venir toutes les organisations
les entreprises les territoires auront
besoin de ce type d'outils afin
d'optimiser leurs investissements et
démontrer les performances
environnementales
des carboni city est la preuve que nous
savons les outiller et les aider dans
leur prise de décision
pour aller plus loin systemx prépare un
programme structurant avec tous ses
partenaires qui souhaitent maîtriser la
conception le déploiement et
l'évaluation des jumeaux numérique
simula bhl pour la digitalisation des
entreprises des services et des
territoires
une des applications concrètes c'est
lorsqu'une ville décide de développer un
nouveau quartier on peut se poser la
question de quel la bonne manière de
raccorder ce quartier à l'énergie est ce
que on prévoit de l'énergie renouvelable
c'est d'énergies renouvelables quel type
d'énergie renouvelable est ce qu'on va
attraper un réseau de chaleur à côté ce
qu'on va faire la géothermie est ce
qu'on va mettre du solaire ce jumeau
numérique cela permet en quelques clics
et de manière très simple d'avoir cette
simulation est de trouver le scénario
énergétique le plus performant cette
composante énergétique c'est la première
qui est développé sur ce jeu numérique
mais on peut imaginer bien évidemment de
nouveaux scénarios que ce soit des
scénarios de mobilité des scénarios de
logements des scénarios d'évolution de
météo etc voilà c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement ouvert qui permet aux
décideurs publics de pouvoir prendre de
bonnes décisions
[Musique]